just remember you drove this story
remember that you made this story the
media ignored this story since late
December but you see how they put this
guy up from Florida I'm not GNA even say
his name then making him the story
trying to conflate the two just so that
you know you drove this story you cannot
stop they're waiting for you to stop you
can't stop stop this is the only thing
that's going to stop the victory mosque
moving on okay my next speaker is coming
to us via video because he couldn't be
here he's speaking elsewhere he is in my
opinion one of the forces that is
slaying the biased mainstream media he's
broken more stories outside of the
mainstream media Andrew
Breitbart Andy Andrew bbot is an icon
and he's indicative of the future and
where media is going you are the future
we are we are looking at the past the
ancient relic of the past in front of us
um and so we're going to go live to the
video can we go to the video
tape alrighty Andrew
bbot first off I'd like to thank Pamela
Geller for Having the courage uh to have
this event today at Ground Zero on this
sacred day this is the right place and
the right time to have this event
because you represent the majority in
this country The Washington Post ABC
poll just came out to show that 66% of
the country is against the building of
this mosque and only
29% favor the building of the mosque and
if you look deeper into the poll you'll
realize that the opposition is
incredibly strong of that 66% % and the
people who want to build that mosque uh
they're not as strong minded about this
so what you have is the majority of the
American people strongly opposing this
yet somehow Pamela Geller and those who
are gathered here are controversial no
you're not controversial Katie kurick is
controversial Charlie Gibson is
controversial uh Brian Williams is
controversial the New York Times is
controversial those people that
represent the minority are acting as if
you're somehow doing something that is
uh morally incorrect well I think the
term that we're talking about is
Politically Incorrect and that is the
problem political correctness got us
into this problem in the first place it
is basically the equivalent of an
ostrich putting his head into the sand
and that is what many in the media Elite
have done since 9/11 while the well
radical Islam is not just killing our
soldiers they're also waging a
propaganda war against us and those who
have read Bernard Lewis those who have
read Mark Stein and those people who
have chosen not to act like ostrich
ostriches have found themselves being
called uh all sorts of names by those
who have acted like ostriches that is
what we face today it's a battle of
those who have the will to face up to
the challenges that we face in America
in 2010 9 years after 911 Americans have
every right to congregate at Ground Zero
at the World Trade Center to represent
the majority point of view do not let
Katie Kirk and her Cavalcade of the
politically correct media Elite don't
tell you that you don't have the right
to be here this is a strong message not
just to the radical islamists that we
have the backbone to stand up to the war
that we Face against them but to those
that would cower in the face of that
Peril our media Elite so thank you very
much Pamela Geller and thank you to all
those who came here today to risk the
consternation of Katie Krick